la contestation de la réforme des
retraites ne faiblit pas après les
rassemblements du 1er mai l'Inter
syndical appelle à une nouvelle journée
de manifestation le 6 mai prochain hier
le cortège Blaise a rassembler entre 4
et 5000 personnes à Tours entre 6600 et
9000 une manifestation qui s'est
déroulée globalement dans le calme à
noter pour la première fois cependant
quelques débordements en fin de
rassemblement Faustine Luneau
[Applaudissements]
7600 manifestants selon la police 9000
selon les syndicats un record pour une
manifestation du 1er mai qui ne dépasse
normalement pas les 2000 à Tours dans le
cortège certains sont des habitués
d'autres n'avaient jamais manifesté un
1er mai mais en pleine réforme des
retraites cette année ce jour de fête du
travail avait une saveur particulière
très particulière bien sûr parce que
avec cette réforme
il faut absolument se battre on est
d'abord il y a du monde on est tous là
ça fait des années que je considère que
ce qui se passe en France c'est
inadmissible et que les citoyens ne
devraient pas laisser passer des choses
comme ça donc je suis très content que
j'ai une plus grosse mobilisation en ce
moment et je suis là pour le montrer
donc je suis déjà venu au 1er mai les
années précédentes mais juste pour
[Musique]
faire ça
continue à faire l'appel au
rassemblement a été entendu aussi dans
les autres communes du territoire avec
notamment près de 5000 manifestants à
Blois en 2023 c'est la première fois
depuis 2009 que les syndicats locaux
manifestaient ensemble un 1er mai on
envoie quand même un message pour dire
que même si la réforme a été promulguée
on reste toujours une île malgré ce
qu'il peut espérer la promesse est tenue
mobilisée mobilisation générale dans la
rue une grosse mobilisation et on l'a
tenu à tours autour de 9000 c'est un bon
chiffre effectivement dans les
manifestations autres que l'on a fait
sur les retraites en inter syndicale
c'est un chiffre qu'on a eu mais pas à
chaque fois et oui c'est une belle
mobilisation le défilé s'est déroulé
sans débordement hormis quelques jets de
peinture sur les vitrines et un bref
moment de tension entre les CRS et une
partie détachée du cortège devant la
préfecture de Tours vers 12h30 une
demi-heure plus tard le calme était
revenu